Speaker 1: So we spoke earlier in the show
about Joe Biden warning Russian President
Vladimir Putin, don't invade Ukraine.
Speaker 2: If you do
Speaker 1: it, we're going to put in place
economic sanctions.
You're not going to like it.
Don't do it.
Well, Tucker Carlson doesn't like it.
He doesn't like what Joe Biden is saying.
Last night, Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson
sided with Russia
Speaker 2: and with Vladimir Putin, saying
the
Speaker 1: president of Russia just wants
to keep his western border secure.
Now, I already told you earlier that Russia
has been massing troops at the border with
Ukraine.
The idea being they're either gauging what
the reaction would be to a potential invasion
or they're actually planning
Speaker 2: an invasion of Ukraine.
Speaker 1: And Joe Biden went to Putin yesterday
and said, Don't invade Ukraine, we will punish
you economically if you do.
Tucker went on a 14 minute rant last night
defending Russia's actions, saying it's Biden
who should be careful because next thing you
know, he might start a war if he threatens
Putin.
So there are so many things here to talk about.
Let's first look at a couple of clips.
Here is Tucker accurately saying, you know,
the risk to Iowans from Putin and Russia is
very low.
And Tucker is absolutely
Speaker 2: right about that.
Speaker 6: We're going to freeze Germany and
Luxembourg, and that's going to teach Vladimir
Putin again.
What you just saw there is a child who has
no idea what she's talking about, but keeps
talking anyway.
We will defend Ukraine, says Joni Ernst.
Remember, this is a senator from Iowa.
So what happens if we don't defend Ukraine?
Joni Ernst Well, kids in Des Moines grow up
to speak Russian.
No one asked her that question.
She's never thought about it for a moment
that all this reading from the same talking
points from Adam Schiff to Roger Wicker to
Joni Ernst.
Speaker 1: Great.
OK, so I mean, Tucker's right is condescending.
He's pathetic.
He's a propagandist, but he's right.
The Russia thing is not a risk to kids in
Iowa, where Joni Ernst is a senator, and I
wish that that had been the perspective so
many more times in American history when we
were doing military engagements.
Speaker 2: Iraq comes to mind as one example,
but
Speaker 1: we aren't talking about military
intervention here, at least not right now,
nor do I support one.
What we're talking about here is economic
sanctions and participating in the shared
defense of Ukraine.
So Tucker continues, we're going to kind of
go back to what he said before the clip.
We just watched take a look.
Speaker 6: But what's so interesting and ought
to make you sit up and pay attention is suddenly
Partizan Republicans are making identical
noises.
Just this afternoon, Senator Roger Wicker
of Mississippi not a genius, famously, but
still a sitting Republican senator, went on
Fox News to say We may need to send American
troops to Ukraine and possibly because this
is an insane or anything.
Think about the use of nuclear weapons.
Got that in our back pocket.
Nuclear weapons.
Roger Wicker, sitting U.S. Senator No one
in Washington laughed at Roger Wicker.
This is so crazy that no one seems aware of
how crazy it is.
They're all just sitting back and listening
to Toria Nuland.
Tell them what we need to do.
How much has this penetrated the psyche of
Washington, D.C.?
Well, here's a sad piece of tape.
This is Joni Ernst is totally affable, nice
Republican, sort of reasonable in most things
from the Midwest, suddenly sounding like a
bloodthirsty warmonger, something like actually
Adam Schiff when she talks about that dastardly
Vladimir Putin.
Speaker 7: He needs to say to Vladimir Putin
that we are no longer going to allow you to
continue with the Nord Stream two pipeline.
We need you to know and understand that we
will defend Ukraine.
We will provide them assistance.
He needs to make that very clear.
Speaker 6: Putin is so bad we're going to
cut off natural gas to Western Europe in retaliation
against him in December.
We're going to freeze Germany and Luxembourg,
and that's going to teach Vladimir Putin again.
What you just saw there is a child who has
no idea what she's talking about, but keeps
talking anyway.
Speaker 1: OK, so then we get to like the
part about Joni Ernst that I played for you
earlier.
So here's the deal with this.
Your reaction might be Republicans just love
Russia.
So of course, Tucker is siding with Russia,
and it is true
Speaker 2: that increasingly under Trump,
these Republicans
Speaker 1: are more and more sort of smitten
by these authoritarian strongmen.
And Russia is is, you know, one example of
that.
But this is actually bigger than that.
And remember, I don't want war with Russia.
I didn't want Trump going to war with Russia.
I don't want Joe Biden going to war with Russia.
Speaker 2: I'm not calling for a
Speaker 1: war with Russia at all, period.
What I want to point out to you is that for
Republicans, the principle is that Democrats
are always in the wrong.
Under Obama, the focus was Bayda.
Obama let Putin take Crimea.
And he just let them do it.
He walked all over Obama once again.
Why didn't Obama go to war?
Why didn't Obama deploy troops?
Why did Obama let Putin do whatever the hell
he wanted?
In Donald Trump, the focus then became why
wouldn't we want to
Speaker 2: get along without
Speaker 1: getting along is good, you know,
their voices would go up throughout.
Putin didn't do anything wrong
Speaker 2: with the let's be
Speaker 1: friends.
Trump is right not to go after Putin.
Trump is right not to treat Putin strongly
and instead treat him with kid gloves.
You warmongering liberals stop saying Trump
should be going aggressive with Putin, and
then now it's Joe Biden.
And now it's well, even merely threatening
economic sanctions is crazy.
Putin's not that bad.
Putin's just protecting his border wall.
But hold the hold on a second, guys.
Under Obama, you flipped out because Obama
didn't stop Putin from taking Crimea.
Now Biden is bad for doing something at least
an economic threat.
Speaker 2: I thought.
Speaker 1: Wasn't this what you said?
Obama was wrong for not doing, and now Biden
is wrong for doing it.
And at the end of the day, these people are
truly pathetic because there are no underlying
values or
Speaker 2: principles with foreign policy.
Speaker 1: The only underlying principle is
attack Democrats.
The principle is it's always the fault of
some Democrat doing something wrong.
Either Democrats did the wrong thing by doing
something or Democrats did the wrong thing
by not doing something,
Speaker 2: or Democrats
Speaker 1: wanted the Republican to do the
wrong thing.
But fortunately, the Republican was smart
Speaker 2: and strong and wise
Speaker 1: enough not to do it under Obama.
Obama was that Democrat.
Speaker 2: Under Trump, it was other
Speaker 1: Democrats saying, why is Trump
treating Putin like this and not taking him
seriously?
And then under Biden, it goes back to being
Joe Biden?
This is amazing, even for Tucker, the defense
of Putin here.
But at this point, I probably shouldn't even
really
be that surprised.